let's go to show is about to start we
got 32 seconds the countdown is crazy
there we go
here we go here we go
here we go
playground games
let's do it
thank God
I showed you
oh yeah
[Music]
it's called a surprise surprise
now you see it no
you want to know what they working on
they're working on your demise
could you imagine Hades with uh four
players 33 players
I guess the cloud do work nothing like
that SSD
oh man what's this water looking
shimmery wait
included presents
hey Spider-Man
yo J dub this is what they paid for
right five years ago right okay you know
what the best part about this is
[Music]
everybody's dead right now let's go uh
necromancing at his finest look at that
now let's go Xbox game
another one hey Spider-Man
oh nobody as well stop
Horizon who they going for the kill Game
Pass no I'm not saying that it don't
look good I'm just saying it's like hold
on Xbox game studios presents hold on we
are another one let him cook son let him
cook they got 30 students
defibrillator we got to revive these
PlayStation people let's see that race
tracing
you're walking
Hold the Line let's go what though is
this road simulator you want to know how
the sewage systems work we got a game
for you
[Music]
no but this is how it happened Clockwork
Revolution